so how am I getting through this it's
called whiskey oh oh I should not have
done that for real
okay so Jessica Jones is back and I have
started watching the second season I got
three episodes in tonight and I'm
calling it an evening on that particular
chunk of it now a little bit of
background Jessica Jones the first
season is my favorite show that Marvel
Netflix has done so far it's my favorite
season of anything
followed by daredevil season 1 and right
off the get-go I've been excited and
nervous about the second season because
I like I said I really like that show
and it was a very complete story
obviously that was more that could
happen to Jessica after but it was very
obvious that that season was geared
towards telling that story that it
finished telling and that's often a very
awkward position for a show to come in
to do a second season on the back of
because when you get through the first
one you did everything you designed the
show to do and how do you come back from
that
to make in comparison that was more or
less my problem with the second season
of stranger things and the back side
comparison I'll probably be making a
little bit because I'm not loving this
right now it's not it's not bad it's not
iron it's not iron fist' bad it's not
the inhumans bad it's nothing like any
of that but it's definitely a big step
down so far it can recover obviously but
I think ultimately its main issue is
honestly almost identical to my problem
with the second season of stranger
things which is that the first season
I had a strong central thrust and a
really good hook by the end of the first
episode I'm three episodes in I've
gotten maybe what's supposed to be the
hook if it is it ain't hooking me well I
know what the the primary hook is but
I'm completely unhooked by it so I
spoiler warning I suppose as I get into
specifics on this so I got really
nervous the person that my the first
time that I saw a trailer where the
emphasis was on I want to know how I got
these powers I want to know what
happened to me and I'm because well look
just on a personal level and I know this
is not the case for everybody but first
off I don't care I don't care how she
got her powers and it feels too much
like trying to capture the lightning in
a bottle that was the first step in the
first season because that first season
really was a wonderful way of
extrapolating past trauma past damage
and and putting it in a superhero
framework in this really well-conceived
manner to go back to a different past
trauma just smacks of trying to do the
same thing again as opposed to moving
things for what I had hoped the second
season would be and even this idea would
have been skeptical up but what I wanted
it to be was just her working cases and
obviously because she could start
working a case that becomes bigger
becomes a bigger deal but it didn't and
that is kind of almost what happens
except it also ties back into her and
where her powers come from and that's
the part I don't want I would have been
down for it if the Whizzer headshot
which first of all fun reference if you
if you have ever heard that name before
he is an actual superhero believe it or
not but when he showed up and I knew the
minute he said that I'm like he's gonna
turn out that I actually have those
powers so I mean the end I'll mention
this a few times I'm calling a lot of
these plot developments which I'm not
loving my ability to do that
so we get him and he wants her help she
doesn't help and then she realizes well
there's some truth to what he's saying
that honestly that's fine and like
there's somebody who's tracking down
people with powers you who aren't you
know like the Hulk in Captain America
and whatnot and you know that's a case
for her to track cool I'm fine with that
except with how it ties back into her
own thing because now we're just
rehashing her doing past damage again
and that's not me saying like she should
just be over it because that's not how
trauma works I get that but we explored
her trauma and there's enough to if you
want to revisit any of that there's
enough just to be taken from the fact
that she is dealing with consequences of
what she did she killed a man if you
want to have her angsty about past
trauma have a ranks the about that not
more stuff that you have to explain
first and now it go through her trauma
about it and and the other thing and
again I'll make the comparison to well
not only just stranger things season two
but really any show where the first
season is based on a strong central
theme and my understanding of Twin Peaks
was that the first season was like this
and the second season kind of meandered
this kind of does the same thing that
the Twin Peaks when I could be wrong I
haven't actually watched it myself
I'm gonna lose geek cred for that
anyways what I mean by that is all the
characters who were in the first season
were there for a reason
they served a narrative purpose they
were contributors to the story in the
second season there's a number of these
characters who are there because they
were in the last season
Hogarth leaps to mind as far as all that
goes and again maybe it'll come together
and they'll be more to her to actually
contribute to what's going on but right
now she's not contributing to this
narrative she's not contributing to this
story we're following her and she gets
this diagnosis but like it the
assumption is she was around last season
so you care about her now right like
it's not that I didn't care about
hogarth she was a decent character but
is there a narrative reason for her to
be here or is she
only here because she was here last time
that's what if again that's what a fair
chunk of stranger things season 2 felt
like that I said that about Mike because
Mike had nothing to do in that second
season and you he what he was doing
there is not something you would create
a character for if that was the first
season as a show you go we should just
cut this guy he doesn't do anything he
was only there because he was there
before and Hogarth I'm getting the same
thing all over again
Trish is contributing I'll give her that
although again talking about things that
I called her new boyfriend I think it
was literally two minutes before he like
sticks his little USB into her computer
starts doing it or who knows what we
don't know exactly what his deal with
yes but um two minutes before we do that
I I thought even odds that he is he's a
bad guy or at the very least involved in
all this and hey look at then there he
goes so again I'm calling these plot
turns I'm calling these twists and the
the show also in these first three
episodes has done the jessica goes to
the next clue point but they're already
dead they do it like three times in a
row and that has gotten really old and
really predictable really quick so yeah
primarily I've been bitching so far
Krysten Ritter still works she's really
good in this part Trish works as a
character and they're dynamic really
works and there's Malcolm I like Malcolm
a lot that he's he's terrific he does a
really good job of helping balance
Jessica in terms of just the general
personalities and their chemistry with
each other so I like that he has more to
do this season than he had last time
around so there's stuff here and you
know maybe the the fake dr. Hanson is
the now the big hook because I'm prior
to this they had friggin Simpson from
the first season who I got I didn't care
I mean that one I aggressively didn't
care about because I found that his his
entire subplot in that first season was
something
I would have just excised from the
entire thing I would have cut up
probably two episodes because that was
about the accumulation of all his stuff
junk him make it two episodes shorter
and that first season probably would
have been perfect as far as I was
concerned so bringing him back is not
only something that doesn't interest me
it makes me actively go like you so the
just it's it's just not moving in much
of a direction and if if Leslie Hanson
fake Leslie Hanson whoever the heck she
turns out to be is our actual primary
villain that's just weak because by
episode three of the first season we had
a we had a real good proper introduction
to kilgrave and he'd been alluded to
even before that we know we didn't know
exactly the history but we knew this guy
was bad news here he is here's what he
can do three episodes into this we've
got there's a mystery in Jessica's past
maybe this woman has something to do
with it thought she ran away and she's
kind of strong okay why do I care and
again maybe people who are more invested
in wanting to know where Jessica's
powers came from maybe they can get into
the main maybe if that is if that is
something that actually interests you
and you care about that maybe this will
work for you
I don't care and since that seems to be
the almost the entirety of what they're
hanging the entire season on then I just
I'm afraid this is gonna become a slog
and it's yeah I'm getting red flags
sitting through these first three
episodes but I'm gonna call it a night
hopefully now that we've gotten somebody
for her to focus on maybe it'll pick up
we'll see
but yeah first three episodes was not
great and I'm gonna try and get through
the rest of the season as quickly as I
can
you know to do follow-up stuff how
quickly I'll get it up whether I'm able
to do the rest of the episodes cover it
with just one video if I might need to
do another two I'm not sure we'll see
how this spaces out over time but
Jessica Jones season two first three
episodes please don't talk to me in the
comments about anything past that cuz
you know spoilers don't be a jerk so any
thoughts on the first three episodes
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it do all
the stuff like subscribe and follow and
patreon and buy t-shirts and links for
all this stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]